he's appeared on some high-profile
stages in his time but few more grand
than this one David Beckham and his LA
Galaxy teammates were guests at the
White House if you're going to be the
butt of anyone's jokes it may as well be
the leader of the free world we also
have a young up-and-comer on the team a
guy named David Beckham I have to say I
gave David a hard time he said I said
half his teammates could be his kids
we're getting old there although you're
holding up better than me last year at
the age of 36
David had his best year in MLS leading
the team with 15 assists he did it
despite fracturing his spine halfway
through the season injuring his
hamstring the week before the
championship game he is tough it is in
fact it is a rare man who can be that
tough on the field and also have his own
line of underwear
that underwear line has certainly
boosted Beckham's fame in the US he
hasn't quite turned football into a
national sport here but brand Beckham is
undoubtedly in the celebrity Premier
League a plan to kick about with the
first lady on the South Lawn was covered
by the weather instead young local
footballers got to ask some questions
what did it take to become the man that
you are today it's about hard work it's
about looking after yourself it's about
eating the right things drinking the
right things and working hard and the
enjoyment part is the biggest part so
and I still love playing soccer like I
did when I was your age
Beckham's hoping for more glory at the
London Olympics that's if he's selected
of course but with friends like this who
knows Greg Milam Sky News Washington